يشيع الاتراك قتلاهم
على جنازات الضحايا الذين قضوا بسبب
الانفجار الذي وقع في شارع الاستقلال
بميدان تقسيم في اسطنبول
تحديدا لذكرى ضحايا الهجوم ولا تزال
المشاعر قويه
قبل 53 سنوات
فهو ليس الارهاب
يطمئنه السكان كشفت شرطه اسطنبول عن هويه
المتهمه بتنفيذ الهجوم وقالت انها امراه
سوريه تدعى احلام البشير وتم تدريبها من
قبل حزب العمال الكردستاني
تلقى التعليمات تنظيم الارهابي الذي امر
بقتلها لمنعنا من فهم ملابسات الهجوم لقد
دخل تركيا
من الاكراد فيما رفض حزب العمال
الكردستاني لاتهامات التركيه شعبنا
والاشخاص الديمقراطيون يعلمون عنك
واننا لن نستهدف المدنيين بشكل مباشر ولا
نقبل اعمالا تستهدفهم
تخشى القوات الكرديه التي تسيطر على مدينه
كوباني في سوريا من انقره تريد استهداف
المدينه حيث تهدد السلطات التركيه بشن
عمليه كبيره ضد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
للحد من نفوذ الاكراد في المنطقه